Karen Horney you talked about something
called The Tyranny issued in this
Society we feel like we should be x y z
should be fit a stronger happier
healthier more productive and these
tyrannical shoulds are what create
divides within us and my worry with the
growth mindset is is that what we're
doing is we're just kind of adding
another should to a long list of other
shoots but I think Carl Rogers put it
really well and he said I am at my
greatest happiest when I strive towards
scores to which I am dimly aware and I
think that's a really interesting way to
look at life because yes we will have
goals yes we will have this kind of
vision in our minds about where we want
to go but at the same time to know that
not always is it going to be a case
where you're going to grow all the time
growth growth growth is fine but too
much can be perfection